go to a breaking news story from this
morning in Syria where Israel is to
blame for the downing of a Russian
military plane off the coast of Latakia
that's according to the Russian Defense
Ministry it claims the Israeli Air Force
used the Isle 20 plane as cover from
Syrian air defenses missiles from which
hit the aircraft 15 crew members died as
a result four Israeli fighter jets had
been targeting Syrian facilities in
Latakia province at the time she did on
the 17th of September at around 10 p.m.
for Israeli fighter jets launched guided
bombs on Syrian military facilities near
the city of Latakia the bombing occurred
in the immediate vicinity of where the
Russian il 20 was coming in to land the
Israeli Jets deliberately created a
dangerous situation the Israeli pilots
used the Russian plane as cover against
the Syrian air defense systems as a
result the Russian il xx was brought
down by a Syrian air defense missile
there's no way the Israeli pilots could
not have seen the Russian plane military
confirms it's Jets had targeted Syrian
facilities but blamed the planes downing
on the Syrian government itself along
with Iran and Hezbollah which Israel
views as a terrorist group
we asked him asked us to comment on the
Israeli allegations and we'll bring you
any response we do get our Middle East
correspondent Paula Slayer has more well
we're hearing from Israeli officials
that any time soon the Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu will hold a
phone conversation with Russian
President Vladimir Putin we're also
hearing from a senior Israeli official
that Israel is maintaining ongoing
contact with the Russian government and
the Russian military officials at all
levels and providing details from the
Israeli army side they have conducted an
initial inquiry and they have released
their statements to put the blame of
this downing of the Russian plane firmly
on the shoulders of Syria they say to
quote that there was extensive
inaccurate and indiscriminate Syrian
anti-aircraft fire that was used they
also point out that when the Russian
plane was downed it was not in the
vicinity where the israeli air force
planes had
to the operation and that it also
happened when Israeli planes were
already back in Israeli airspace now the
Israeli Defense Forces has issued a
statement in which it expressed regret
regret had said it mourned the the
killing of fifteen Russian servicemen
and while it acknowledged that it had in
fact carried out these bombings in Syria
as I say it did not put the blame on its
shoulders take a listen
Israel expresses sorrow for the death of
the aircrew members of the Russian plane
that was down tonight due to Syrian
anti-aircraft fire Israel holds the
Assad regime whose military shut down
the Russian plane fully responsible for
this incident now in that same statement
the Israeli army went on to say that it
had notified its Russian counterparts
using existing communication mechanisms
of its Air Force operations now this
does seem to contradict what came out of
a phone conversation earlier between the
Russian Defense Minister Sergei shoigu
and his Israeli counterpart Avigdor
Lieberman in that conversation the
Russian Defense Minister said that there
was less than a minute before the
Russian plane was hit that the Israelis
informed the Russian side of the
operation he also said that there was no
way that the pilots could not have seen
the Russian plane that was landing from
a altitude of some five kilometers now
15 servicemen were killed it happened at
around 10 o'clock last night Monday
night local time the Russian plane was
on its way back to the Hammerman Air
Force Base near the Syrian city of
Latakia it was some 35 kilometers off
the Syrian coast when it lost radar
signal the Israelis used four f-16
fighter jets to strike a number of
targets inside Syria one of which was a
power station and reports are that some
seven people on the ground were injured
from those strikes at the same time
there was a French frigate that was
firing from the Mediterranean Sea on the
ground right now in Syria there is a
search and rescue operation underway so
on a diplomatic level we're waiting to
hear more from the Israeli side and
looking towards this phone conversation
that will happen between
Prime Minister Netanyahu and President
Putin other downed Russian plane was an
IL 20 it's a Patrol military aircraft
known by NATO as coot top speed of
nearly 700 kilometers an hour quite a
big wingspan as well it's renowned for
its durability the L 20 has been in
service since Soviet times according to
the manufacturer this one was due to
remain there until around 2020 now
Russia's Defense Minister has said that
Israel used the Russian jet as cover for
airstrikes as it expected Syria wouldn't
respond I've led me Putin agreed with
Sergei shoigu findings adding that the
downing of the plane was the consequence
of a tragic chain of events well we're
now joined we should be ensuring live
any minute by political writer and
commentator Marwa Osman well that's
that's going to happen a bit later when
we do get her on line now we heard that
press conference earlier from mr. Putin
and the prime minister of Hungary Auburn
where mr. Putin said there would be a
response from Russia as well which would
guarantee the safety and security of
Russian personnel and infrastructure in
Syria that response would be visible
straight away that's according to mr.
Putin now last night's incident wasn't
the only Israeli action in Syria against
the military targets I discussed
previous cases earlier with artis natira
Tudor and the reason why Russia are
pointing the finger at the Israelis is
because of those past hostile actions
saying that Israeli forces often took
aim at Syrian targets so if we go back
rewind to the 10th of February 2018
that's where an israeli f-16 fighter jet
crashed after being hit by syrian
defenses during an offensive in syria
the two pilots parachuted to safety
before the crash
in northern Israel and it's believed
that that was the first time that Israel
lost one of its jets during these are in
conflict the plane was hit during air
strikes which happened in response to an
Iranian drone going into Israeli
territory that drone was shot down
and then Israel later launch further
strikes what we do have here is the
explanation from the Israeli PM Benjamin
Netanyahu as to the motivation behind
that attack I've been warning for some
time about the dangers of Iran's
military entrenchment in Syria Iran
seeks to use a Syrian territory to
attack Israel for its professed goal of
destroying Israel this morning Iran
brazenly violated Israel's sovereignty
they dispatched an Iranian drone from
Syrian territory into Israel and this
demonstrates that our warnings were 100%
correct
Israel holds Iran and its Syrian host
responsible for today's aggression we
will continue to do whatever is
necessary to protect our sovereignty and
our security now following that incident
a phone call did take place between
President Putin and Prime Minister
Netanyahu and they agreed that military
coordination with regards to Syria must
continue they also agreed that they
needed to avoid any steps that would
lead to new confrontation in the region
that was according to Interfax news now
I'll explain a couple more incidents on
the 9th of April Russia and Syria
accused Israel of carrying out strikes
against t4 airbase which is near Palmyra
in central Syria the Russian Defense
Ministry they said that Israel an
Israeli aircraft launched a tow missiles
five of those were intercepted by Syrian
air defense systems and just one month
on if we go forward there was a
face-to-face meeting between Putin and
Netanyahu on the 8th of May in 2018 and
and unless me who came out after that
meeting and said but Russia was unlikely
to limit actions in Syria Israeli
actions in Syria two days after that
meeting another incident happened and we
can't forget the Syrian reaction
considering that these airstrikes are
taking place without a UN Landin this
aggressive conduct by the Zionist entity
will lead to nothing but an increase in
tensions in the region what we do know
is that the Syrian government invited
Russia to help during the Syrian civil
war back in 2015 and Russia has almost
turned a blind eye to these Israeli
strikes have been taking place they've
been feeling that they been acting as
diplomats in a very complex region
mediating between the various players
Israel being one of them so if we look
at the bigger picture and at this latest
incident which took part took place at
10 p.m. local time on the 17th of
September the Russian Ministry of desert
defense is saying that the Israeli jet
hid behind the Russian plane which led
to it being set on fire
that's a bold accusation from Russia and
maybe it's because of these continuous
airstrikes that would have been going on
despite the fact that Israel and Russia
have been allies they have been claiming
to be Friends of Russia and and that's a
contradiction in itself from the Russian
perspective it's almost like a betrayal
for them so there's no doubt the
tensions between the two nations have
grown a sultan mahmud Holly a former
member of the Pakistan Air Force gave us
his reaction to the incident but what as
a former aircrew has a former flyer I
can analyze and give you my personal
opinion I could be wrong but I believe
that you see in this particular case
there is a possibility that Russia is a
right that this bigger radar shadow of
the Isle 20 was used as a cover by the
for attacking Israeli f-16 fighter
aircraft because please remember that in
February for the first time and Israeli
f-16 was shot down by a similar missile
and this time there is a chance that
they may not be willing to take the risk
of you know facing the fire coming from
the Syrian side and they may have taken
cover of the bigger aircraft now you see
I've flown in that area and I know very
well that there are there are radar and
contacts available the Israelis must be
monitoring it and there are Israeli
controllers who speak the Russian
language they could have forewarned this
particular aircraft but the warning
which came only a minute short of it was
far too late that means that the die had
been cast and these 16 aircrew and the
ill-fated il 20 had already been
sacrificed to save those four f-16s I
mean this is my personal opinion who has
given permission to the Israelis to come
and bomb them over there the United
Nations is there Mossad is supposed to
be one of the top most intelligence
agencies in the world why can't it share
its information with Russia or more
importantly with the United Nations
which can take action over there if they
are going to take clandestine action and
they also claim that they have done it
200 times earlier then I think such an
accident was waiting to happen and I'm
sorry for the time being prima facie it
seems Israel is to be blamed Russia's
foreign ministry summoned the Israeli
ambassador over Monday night's events
reports are coming in that the Israeli
prime minister plans to hold a phone
conversation with Vladimir Putin very
shortly today we have discussed with the
director of nasus think-tank a Marwick
off how exactly relations between Russia
and Israel are likely to play out after
this well what we expect as a first
response is to limit
Israeli capability inside Syria and
probably Lebanese airspace the Israelis
are not going to be given free hand
anymore we think it would be the natural
response because there will be there
have they must have been a lot of
pressure on Russia from Syrian
leadership from the Syrian thereon and
saying look these people are our
reigning free we can't stop them you
don't upgrade our systems our systems
are too old and you don't participate in
this now Russia has been a victim of
these shenanigans itself so it can make
you know a step forward in this and can
draw a line and say okay no more Israeli
intervention otherwise we will take
action and we will
we've always warned against Russian
servicemen being targeted and now it
happened we're not gonna allow this
anymore so this is the first response
that we expect
you